aymeric montville hauteur de julian
assange en danger de mort aux éditions
delga se dit satisfait de cette décision
de la justice américaine cour d'appel en
fait à a statué en fait sur l'ensemble
sur l'ensemble donc de la faire mais
surtout sur l'ensemble des écoutes en
disant qu'elle était inconstitutionnelle
tout ça nous ramène en fait au patriot
act c'est à dire la la loi qui a été
choisi par par george bush après après
le bénin qui est une loi de fêtes de
sécurité ils ont extrêmement pensez donc
edouard snowden évidemment est celui qui
a dénoncé tout ce système qui voulait il
est celui qui a qui alloue me mis en
cause en fait ces époux de généraliser
ce système lui-même a changé parce que
maintenant depuis 2015 et il est donc
deux ans après les faits les états unis
ont compris qu'en fait enfin trouver
d'autres solutions c'est à dire en fait
de confier la surveillance aux aux
agences de télécommunications en prenant
les données si nécessaire donc c'est pas
ce combat de ce modèle n'est pas n'est
pas totalement terminé d'ailleurs se
profile en fait non pas à une écoute
tout simplement de l'année ça mais il
n'écoute par l'epareca phare en fait
c'est un autre problème qui commence